Tach zusammen, Jack Pop hier.
Willkommen zum zweiten Teil unseres großen Monster-Checks. In der letzten Folge haben wir uns ja schon King Kong vorgenommen.
Und weil wir nicht wollen, dass sich hier jemand vernachlässigt
fühlt, ist heute der echte König der Monster dran...
Godzilla!
Der hat einen Signature-Move und das ist sein Hitzestrahl.
So ganz genau erklären, was der denn jetzt
ist, dass versuchen die Filme gar nicht erst,
aber kein Problem. Dafür haben wir eine Physikerin im Team.
Hi Anne!
Hi!
Ich habe mir den Hitzestrahl mal genauer angeschaut,
um herauszufinden, woraus der genau bestehen könnte.
Und was soll ich sagen? Das, was
Godzilla da spuckt, ist nicht nur Hitze.
Das ist viel gefährlicher und zerstörte Städte
wären echt das geringste Problem.
Anne am Anfang: Welches Team?
Team King Kong. Aber ehrlich gesagt auch nur,
weil ich bei „SchleFaZ“, den schlechtesten
Filmen aller Zeiten, mal den alten
"King Kong vs. Godzilla“ gesehen habe und da gab's
ein Trinkspiel. Man musste sich für ein Team
entscheiden, mit entsprechendem Cocktail,
und der King Kong Ding Dong Sching Schong
Bing Bong Sing-Along hat mich einfach überzeugt.
Sorry, aber das catcht mich null.
Ich habe den Trailer gesehen und habe gedacht, was
will der Affe überhaupt? Godzilla hat den
Hitzestrahl, der muss nur einmal den Mund
aufmachen… dann gibt es Grill-Gorilla.
Also sorry, aber ich habe mich für das offensichtliche
Kampf-Feature entschieden. Wie ist es denn
bei Euch? Was seid Ihr? Team King Kong oder
Team Godzilla? Schreibt es mal in die Kommentare!
Ja, Du hast schon irgendwie recht.
Godzilla ist physikalisch betrachtet ziemlich krass.
In jedem Film ist am Ende mindestens
eine Großstadt völlig zerstört.
Und das liegt nicht nur an den gigantischen Kämpfen,
sondern eben auch an Godzillas Hitzestrahl.
Bevor wir jetzt die Physik auspacken, lass
uns erst mal schauen, wie dieser Hitzestrahl
in den verschiedenen Filmen gezeigt und dargestellt
ist. Und da haben wir unseren liebsten Film-Nerd
gefragt, nämlich Alper vom Kanal Cinema Strikes
Back.
Hi Anne, Hi Jack.
Natürlich, der Hitzestrahl ist extrem cool
und gehörte schon von Anfang an zu Godzilla.
Schon im ersten Film des Studios Toho konnte
man ihn sehen, damals natürlich noch in Schwarz-Weiß.
Der erste Godzilla-Farbfilm kam erst acht Jahre
später heraus und seitdem leuchtet
der Strahl meistens blau. Insgesamt hat Toho
32 Godzilla-Filme produziert, vier kamen dann
noch aus den Vereinigten Staaten dazu.
Nämlich Roland Emmerichs „Godzilla“ und die drei
Filme des aktuellen Monster-Verse.
Und in dem 62er „King Kong vs Godzilla“, da gab
es sogar einen kleinen Hinweis auf das blaue Leuchten...
(It looks like a Tscherenkow-Light)
Da wird von Tscherenkow-Licht gesprochen.
Aber weil das was Wissenschaftliches ist
und ich noch nicht mal weiß, wie man das richtig
ausspricht, spiele ich den Ball wie King Kong in den 60ern wieder zu Euch.
Das musst Du uns erklären, was ist das?
Tscherenkow-Light beziehungsweise auf Deutsch
Tscherenkow-Strahlung ist was richtig megacooles.
Und zwar passiert das, wenn geladene Teilchen
- wie zum Beispiel Elektronen - sich schneller als Licht bewegen.
Da muss ich jetzt den Spielverderber machen und sagen, dass sich nichts schneller als das Licht bewegen kann.
Aber der Trick ist, dass es sich dabei nicht
um die Lichtgeschwindigkeit im Vakuum handelt,
sondern in einem Medium. Und da kann das Licht
auch deutlich langsamer werden, wie zum Beispiel
in Wasser, wo es dann nur noch 75% der Ausgangsgeschwindigkeit hat. Im gleichen Moment behalten die Elektronen
aber ihre Geschwindigkeit fast bei und können
so schneller als dass Licht sein.
Und das führt zu einem ziemlich coolen Effekt,
der auch noch sehr Godzilla-mäßig aussieht.
Da gibt es nämlich so ein blaues Leuchten,
dass man typischerweise in den Wasserbecken
von Kernreaktoren erkennt. Ich habe da ein
ziemlich beeindruckendes Video gefunden,
nämlich eins von einem amerikanischen Forschungsreaktor,
der ganz langsam hochgefahren wird und da
sieht man, wie von Minute zu Minute dieses
Leuchten im Wasser immer krasser und krasser wird.
Anne da musst Du mir jetzt aber physikalisch
aushelfen, was passiert da jetzt ganz genau?
Es ist so, das bewegte Ladungsträger
elektromagnetische Strahlung, also Lichtwellen,
aussenden und zwar egal wie schnell sie sind
und auch in alle Richtungen. Wenn jetzt aber
das Elektron langsamer als das Licht ist,
dann heben sich diese Lichtwellen gegenseitig auf
und wir sehen überhaupt nichts. Wenn
es aber schneller als das Licht ist,
dann entsteht eine Lichtwellen-Front. Und das ist
dann das blaue Leuchten.
Das heißt, es ist wie bei einem Überschallflugzeug.
Das bewegt sich ja auch schneller als der Schall.
Und dann gibt es da auch eine Schallwellen
Front und den Knall und bei Tscherenkow-Strahlung
ist es quasi ein Lichtknall.
Also kein Knall, sondern eben dieses blaue Leuchten?
Könnte man so sagen. Aber ich muss jetzt
ein bisschen fies sein und zwar glaube ich nicht,
dass der Hitzestrahl tatsächlich Tscherenkow-Strahlung
ist.
Orr Anne… das wäre so eine schöne und
elegante Lösung gewesen. Und filmkonform!
Tut mir auch mega leid! Aber das Ding ist,
Godzilla macht seinen Hitzestrahl in der Luft
und nicht im Wasser. Und in der Luft ist die
Lichtgeschwindigkeit fast die von Vakuum.
Und dass das Elektronen da diese Geschwindigkeit
aufbringen, ist super unwahrscheinlich.
Aber ihr habt immerhin etwas gelernt.
Okay, wenn Tscherenkow-Strahlung jetzt raus ist,
dann müssen wir uns anschauen, was für
Eigenschaft der Hitzestrahlen noch hat.
Und ich sage mal so: das Offensichtlichste beim
Hitzestrahl ist ja wohl die Hitze und die
gab es schon im ersten Godzilla Film von 1954.
Da schmilzt der Stahl einfach so als wäre das Butter.
Und im Jahr 2000 ist noch mal ein Godzilla Guide rausgekommen.
Da steht drin, dass der Hitzestrahl bis zu 500.000°C
warm sein kann. Das finde ich schon ziemlich krass.
Ist es überhaupt möglich?
Also in Extremsituationen auf der Erde ist
es schon möglich. Atombomben haben kurz nach
der Explosion in etwa 300.000°C und das geht
ja schon ein bisschen in die Richtung.
Ist also nicht super unrealistisch. Was aber Peanuts
für Godzilla sind, ist das mit dem Stahl schmelzen.
Denn Stahl hat eine Schmelztemperatur
von 1.500°C.
Okay, aber was können wir daraus ableiten?
Also was sagen jetzt diese krassen Temperaturen
und dieses blaue Leuchten über die Physik
von Godzillas Hitzestrahl?
Die verraten uns, das Godzilla einfach das
krasseste Monster auf der ganzen Welt ist.
Denn damit wird ein für alle Mal geklärt,
dass der Strahlen nicht etwa Feuer oder ein
Laser ist, sondern einfach ionisierende Strahlung.
Die entsteht zum Beispiel beim Zerfall von radioaktiven Elementen.
Und das Radioaktivität da reinspielt,
das sehen wir in den Film ja ganz häufig. In
der einen Szene wird ein geschwächter Godzilla
wieder aufgepäppelt, indem die eine Atombombe
in seiner Nähe zünden und er quasi dann
damit wieder aufgeladen wird. Wenn ihr mehr
zum Thema Radioaktivität wissen wollt,
dazu haben wir eine ganze Folge gemacht, die verlinke
ich Euch mal hier oben.
Aber Anne, wenn da jetzt ionisierende Strahlung
rauskommt, was genau heißt ironisieren?
Ionisieren bedeutet, dass einem Atom ein oder
mehrere Elektronen entrissen werden,
dann sind sie nicht mehr neutral, sondern positiv geladen.
Dazu braucht es relativ viel Energie, denn
ein Elektron zu klauen bedeutet nichts anderes,
als dem Elektron so viel Energie zu geben,
dass es gegen die Anziehungskraft vom Atomkern ankommt.
Und dafür gibt es auch Beispiele aus dem echten Leben.
Leider, muss man sagen. Denn
bei der Reaktorkatastrophe von Tschernobyl
gibt es Berichte von einem Fischer, der auch
ein blaues Leuchten während der Explosion
gesehen hat. Und ein Alltagsphänomen - das
kennen wir alle - sind Blitze. Gewitterblitze.
Genau. Auch da wird die Luft ironisiert und
leuchtet dann blau. Bei anderen Elementen wären das übrigens andere Farben.
Das können wir Euch sogar zeigen.
Wir habenein sehr, sehr schönes, klassisches, chemisch-physikalisches Schauexperiment vorbereitet und werden jetzt
einfach mal Godzillas Hitzestrahl basteln.
Die Uni Leipzig hat uns etwas ziemlich Cooles ausgeliehen.
Nicht diesen Godzilla sondern
dass hier.
Das sind Gasentladungsröhren. Da sind verschiedene
Gase drin und die können wir jetzt auch ironisieren.
Und dann leuchten die in verschiedenen Farben.
Das kennt man am besten von einer Neonreklame.
Eine Neonröhre funktioniert genauso. Da kommen
verschiedene Farben raus. Wir machen das aber
logischerweise nicht mit ionisierender Strahlung,
wir wollen nämlich noch ein paar
Science vs. Fiction-Episoden rausbringen!
Genau! Deswegen benutzen wir hier den Hochspannungsgenerator, denn wir können Gase auch mit elektrischer Energie anregen.
Wie haben hier die Hauptbestandteile von Luft
in den Röhren.
Wir haben Stickstoff, Sauerstoff und Kohlendioxid.
Und dann gucken wir mal, in welchen Farben
die leuchten, wenn wir die ironisieren.
Das sieht schon sehr, sehr cool aus!
Das ist jetzt Stickstoff!
Dann kann ich zu Sauerstoff umschalten.
Dann fass ich Godzilla kurz zwischen die Beide
und haben noch Kohlendioxid.
Das sieht so cool aus… und Anne jetzt mal
ernsthaft: Wenn wir das kombinieren,
dann haben wir Godzillas Hitzestrahl!
Experimente machen Spaß. Aber wenn wir ganz ehrlich sind,
so ein atomarer Atem von Godzilla
macht keinen Spaß mehr. Wie würde der das überleben?
Vermutlich gar nicht. Zumindest nicht,
wenn er ein normales Reptil ist. Aber es ist Godzilla,
da ist alles möglich!
Vielleicht hat er einfach eine Speiseröhre
aus Blei. Das würde zumindest die Strahlung
abschirmen. Aber dann kommt die Hitze und
wir alle kennen ja Bleigießen und da schmilzt
sogar das Teelicht schon das Blei.
Funktioniert also nicht. Da müssen wir festhalten,
Godzilla kann das halt. Ist halt einfach so.
Schwieriger wird es ja auch bei uns.
Ionisierende Strahlung ist nicht so cool für uns.
Nein, wir haben ja vorhin schon gesagt,
dass das die Elektronen aus dem Atom reist, also
auch aus unseren Körperatomen.
Das heißt, unsere DNA und Zellen können beschädigt
werden.
Das hat man ja gerade bei den Nachwirkungen
von Tschernobyl gesehen, was da für Krankheiten
aufgetreten sind und dass sich das teilweise
noch über Generationen gezogen hat.
Wenn wir das mal auf Godzilla zurückbeziehen,
dann müssten wir sagen, das überall wo er
seinen Fuß hinsetzt verbrannte Erde ist.
Im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes.
Also nicht auszumalen, was das für Schäden
weltweit wären… beziehungsweise…
Eigentlich wollen wir uns das schon ausmalen. Eigentlich
wollen wir das ganz genau wissen! Dafür muss
uns noch mal Alper helfen. Alper sag uns mal:
Wo war denn Godzilla, in seiner über 60-jährigen Karriere, überall unterwegs?
Ich sage es mal so. Wir hier in Europa haben bisher Glück gehabt,
denn bei uns hat Godzilla noch nichts verwüstet. Aber so einen Godzilla vs. Kong
in Wanne-Eickel wäre schon ein interessantes,
filmisches Experiment.
Ganz anders ist die Lage in Japan. Die meisten
Filme wurden nicht nur dort produziert, natürlich
spielen sie auch dort. Tokio zum Beispiel
ist gleich mehrfach zerstört worden.
Aber auch Osaka, Kyoto und diverse Inseln ringsum
Japan wurden von Godzilla schon in Schutt
und Asche gelegt. Wer also Angst vor Godzilla
hat, sollte dort besser keinen Urlaub machen.
Und genauso würde ich auch von Reisen nach
Hongkong, New York, Boston und San Francisco abraten.
Denn auch diese Städte hat Godzilla
schon zum Strahlen gebracht.
Da sind gerade jede Menge Reiseziele von unserer
Urlaubsliste gestrichen worden.
Da wären jetzt massig Großstädte mit Strahlen verseucht.
Voll, und das ist so viel schlimmer als der materielle Schaden. Die Reaktorkatastrophe von Tschernobyl war vor 35 Jahren,
und Sperrzone mit einem Radius von 30km gibt es
heute noch.
Und sogar hier in Deutschland können wir
die Auswirkungen noch spüren. Es gibt immer
noch einige Waldgebiete mit strahlenverseuchten
Wildschweinen.
Das heißt, wir hätten, wenn es Godzilla
geben würde, überall auf der Welt riesige
verseuchte Gebiete und könnten dort nicht
mehr hin. Wir hätten Krebsschäden, Strahlenschäden…
Gut, dass wir uns hier im Bereich der Fiktion
befinden.
Wie hat Euch diese Folge gefallen? Lasst mal
einen Kommentar dazu da und schaut Euch auf
jeden Fall, wenn Ihr es noch nicht gemacht
habt, den ersten Teil von unserem großen Monster-Check an.
Den Link dazu packe ich noch mal in die Endcard.
Dank geht raus an Alper, der hat uns jetzt
schon zum dritten Mal mit coolen Filmfacts ausgeholfen!
Vielen, vielen Dank!
Danke an die Chemie-Fakultät der Uni Leipzig.
Die haben uns mit ihren coolen Leuchtstoffröhren
spielen lassen. Und dann bleibt nur noch zu sagen...
abonniert den Kanal und…
die Glocke drücken!
Da können wir uns bald wiedersehen. Ich freue mich darauf, bis dahin!
(Gib der Mutti mal ein Kussi)
(Was sagt uns jetzt diese krasse Temperatur und das blaue Leuchten? Was sagen die uns über die Physik von Gedzissa… Godzissa…)
(Okay, bla bla bla… Spaghetti, Spaghetti, geile Soße, Pilze und außerdem eine Rasierklinge.)